[Musique]
la délégation en droit des femmes du
Sénat travaille actuellement sur un gros
dossier depuis le début de l'année santé
des femmes au travail et le groupe
Carrefour un communiqué il y a à peu
près un mois et demi sur un dispositif
qu'ils ont mis en place notamment pour
les femmes qui s'ouvrentriose et donc
avec aussi un dispositif d'information
de partage
pour les femmes en souffrant dans le
métriose c'est 12 jours par an ensuite
en annoncé également que trois jours en
premier personne qui font face à une
fausse couche et enfin pour
l'implantation de lors d'une d'un
parcours PMA
avec les mesures qui a annoncé mon
entreprise se sent mieux on se sent
mieux dans l'entreprise et on se sent
mieux aussi par rapport à nos équipes
mais aussi par rapport à notre
hiérarchie
est-ce que vous avez des troubles
musculo-squelettiques
quand on a des gros arrivages qui
arrivent directement au palais on les
glisse on glisse la palette en dessous
et ça ne réduit la manutention du tout
sur ces produits là
[Musique]
la tablette qui remonte et qui descend
avec le poids c'est super et le
marche-pied c'est absolument
indispensable pour elle
donc ça mérite évidemment un retour sur
expérimentation mais bien entendu la
méthode est intéressante parce que c'est
vraiment un outil adapté à cette santé
des femmes qui peut parfois bloquer dans
le travail et donc une incapacité à
travailler une incapacité qui n'est pas
forcément reconnue sur laquelle on
communiquait pas jusque alors